I've mentioned this before but I want to
mention it again there's another hot new
video streaming service about to join
the fray yeah that's right here's their
latest promo hey Lu hot shot streaming
services take a hike because there's a
new king in town
Conan Max Plus with exclusive content
you want including unboxing videos for
Panasonic landline phones all the
exterior ten shots from the Great
British Bake Off Mario Lopez's extra at
the movies on the Red Roof Inn welcome
channel the very best angry eruptions at
Cape Cod town hall meetings all the solo
shots of that TMZ guy with the
dreadlocks and 30 hours of rushing belly
face whistling and Cohen Max Plus meets
sports including the best of Major
League Baseball's rain delays a point of
no return with the dirt our two from
every Houston marathon and the best of
bowling alley scorekeeping animations
and if you like movies fasten your seat
belts because conan max plus has all the
films of tom wilkinson plus original
content including live with Kelly and
Ryan but not that Kelly and Ryan plus if
you sign up in the next 48 hours
you'll get Disney chairman Robert
Uyghurs username and password for Disney
plus 13x plus or try a budget streaming
services coming Plus Conan minus 2/7
anna conan / 9 times the square root of
telemundo - hallmark movies times the
Golf Channel Plus c-span 3 - x where x
equals t LC / al jazeera times e to the
6th power
conan max + coming spring 2022 the
Asmara valley district Avera trail
[Applause]